now generally speaking when you think
about how all of this works right you
have information if you have rules and
out of that draw a conclusion so we sort
of have this general pattern there's
data and that leads to a decision okay
you think about what you do and then you
make a choice based on what they're not
computers actually do these as kind of
simultaneous they can look at you can
start on this end we're just our batter
to go from one to the other
here's what I mean right right and by
the way let me give you names on this
and then I'll transfer those were done
to the decision okay it's called forward
change because as it might be going
forward from data to the decision you
know make of it or gene now you may or
the system start from a decision and go
back to what's done yeah that might seem
a bit backwards to you which is why it's
gone back regime but actually as you'll
see in a minute
as humans we use both of these on a
regular basis all the time
my question is trying to imply this
right sometimes once useful and
sometimes the others and sometimes a
combination of both so let me try to
explain to do think backwards
other side of backward chaining okay
back the chain now the idea is I want to
make some kind of decision right so I
think I was talking to the weather
before and whether I should wear
okay now for set for seven I get up in
the morning and I'll tell you a lot I'm
about to pick some coffee
now that question should I wear a jump
on extra chocolate today that's the
decision right so actually my starting
point the starting point a blanket
confusing here's a decision and I want
to know whether I should do it or not or
what kind of variables there are they're
like Michigan for example that so in
that case I've actually begun here on
this side a backward chain right
so now that I've started with my
decision I need to see should I do it or
not so now I've got to go search your
sub garden that relates to that decision
okay let's go huh I checked the well
right off you know Wi-Fi damn something
like that so I look out the window
I don't put an open advise the air
coming through cold or not so you can
see starting with this decision guys
what data I should look at does that
make sense so in some ways you might
think that this is a convergent approach
right I have a sort of God goal in mind
and I'm so drilling towards that and
once I've got enough information then I
don't need to look at anything else I
can make no decision as packaging as
foraging well as the name implies you
just start with the decision you're
gonna make
you might have no idea what decision
you're going to do instead you just stop
in the dog
what do you mind right gather as much to
order as you can just get everything
look you don't know whether it's going
to be relevant or not just grab it once
you got all of that try your best
combine everything you've got here like
and see all right what does this mean to
what decision or decisions maybes leave
it boy now with the clothing that wasn't
such a good example for our food chain
that was more a backward changed
situation start with the decision look
for some data okay
but just yesterday I
the decision which was forward changed
which was who should I choose to be the
three people to get points for best and
fairest after squat
okay so if you don't know the system
best and fairest for great sport you
don't just pick one person who gets the
award you actually need three and they
get three points two points one point
okay and at the end of the season you
add up everyone's points and then you
get an overall best fair and here's the
thing um I have I have 24 people like to
team actually I didn't get 12 people to
play a game yesterday because
unfortunately our bees didn't our bees
are so awesome they intimidating the
other tournament editor so you know so I
just had 12 players to choose from okay
so I go and look at my list right now if
I want to backward changes it would look
something like this
okay look at play number one should this
person get points for bested Ferris
so there's my decision that after then
right and then figure out okay what data
relates to that so then I think back to
the game I'm okay they do this oh the
doctor ball their office scored there
and so on okay so then I don't think
okay now that I've got much out of the
can I make a decision on that yes or no
or it might be you point to one point
where well you can start to see why this
is a problematic approach to this
particular problem right because having
started with this decision I'm going to
do it again yeah
it's a very time-consuming process in
this example so instead I'm going to
start with the dark I'll put it down go
back to the game first rather than any
particular decision and refund again
okay this is what happened this is what
stood out this was unusual this doesn't
usually happen and I'll click OK
based on all of that data I'm going to
make a decision that this will be a
person who I think stood out the most
and they're going to get three ones
there so because it begins with the data
this is often called a data-driven
approach it's often what works best when
you simply don't know which choice is to
actually start asking like all you can
do is look at the situations and well
what do we know and therefore what
decisions can we make on the basis of it
it's often also very helpful when is not
just one thing attitude you're actually
going to end up with a few different
conclusion right so is this in my
knowledge base my rules might be things
like if someone scores right well I
would all the people maybe out three
players and I'd say okay they're going
to be my top contenders for best
interest right so there's a rule that's
fired that's that's people later that's
been relevant right and then I'll have a
look at other rules and I'll put that
all together and I'll see you who are my
top three so yeah it's a different way
of today I want to clarify the
difference between